[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir le 78 lactu sur TVfil 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale voici
les titres de ce jeudi le vélodrome de
SaintQuentin en Yveline enfin ouvert au
publici les réactions des premiers
utilisateurs qui découvrent l'équipement
en ce mois de
janvier les zones d'éducation
prioritaire les ZEP concernent
aujourd'hui 20 % des collégiens des
lycéens des moyens supplémentaires mais
pour quel résultat le ministre annonce
des changements pour 2014 nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure avec notre
invité membre du syndicat enseignant
FSU le centre de luxe a pris réduit au
clés sousbois one nation Paris vient
d'ouvrir le mois dernier et pour les
commerçaux installés c'est aussi l'heure
des soldes quel bilan après une semaine
alors que la tendance nationale est
plutôt
mitigée l'image du jour le pont de la
verrière le pont chuler qui relie la
ville à morpa il est régulièrement
saturé aux heures de pointe car il est
le principal point d'accès à la gare
depuis des années la question de son
doublement est évoquée il semblerait que
les choses avancent la ville vient de
voter le principe du passage à deux fois
de voix avec un passage dédié au bus les
travaux débuteraient en 2015 pour 12
mois reste à valider le financement par
l'ensemble des partenaires morpa la
communauté d'agglomération encore l'état
montant total de ses travaux 8 million
d'euros ouvert officiellement depuis
quelques jours le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin en yeline accueille déjà
de nombreux cyclistes sur piste mais le
site permet aussi de pratiquer d'autres
sports comme le badminton ou encore le
self défense Antony Resche vous propose
une visite guidée c'est leur toute
première prise de contact avec lesécin
de 50 ans en yeline et même si cette
dizaine de cyclistes sont des pistars
confirmés les exigences de l'anneau du
Vélodrome les obligent à reprendre les
bases c'est toute une façon de pédaler
qui est différente de la route avec un
vélo sans sans frein un pignon fixe on
travaille d'abord une une mise en train
c'est-à-dire une séance de entre 20 et
25 minutes d'échauffement avec leur
apprendre à avoir la la science du train
c'està-dire de pas faire d'accélération
et après on a fait des petits des petits
des petits exercices deapendre à se
mettre en danseuse après une heure
passée sur la selle ces cyclistes ont du
mal à quitter cette piste unique au
monde au début c'est surprenant mais
après avec avec l'habitude on commence à
monter d'ailleurs on a fait un exercice
là plusieurs où on a monté à moitié au
3/4 de la piste mais c'est tout de même
impressionnant j'ai tourné à Manchester
j'ai tourné à roubé et là la première
impression le rendement il est
exceptionnel il y a vraiment un
rendement et je pense que c'est une
piste qui permettra de battre des
records rien que pour la première
journée d'ouverture la piste a accueilli
plus d'une centaine de cyclistes
l'abonnement annuel vous coûtera 250 €
mais au sein du Vélodrome il n'y a pas
que du cyclisme au milieu de l'aair
centrale juste derrière moi se trouvent
des terrains de badminton libre à la
location et dans les través du
Clairfontaine du cyclisme français vous
pourrez découvrir le self kick défense
la salle d'entraînement n'est pas encore
terminée mais les passionnés sont déjà
au rendez-vous ici les élèves apprennent
à se défendre avec des simulations de
situation du quotidien mais aussi touche
au sport de combat comme le kickboxing
ou le penchakila 10 mois de cours de
self kick défense vous couteront près de
400 €. voilà pour cette découverte des
coulisses du Vélodrome qui vient
d'ouvrir les zones ucation prioritaire
des secteurs dans lesquels se trouvent
des collèges des lycées qui bénéficient
de moyens supplémentaires pour faire
face à l'échec scolaire elles existent
depuis 1981 dans le secteur des ivelines
on peut notamment citer celle de trappe
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a présenté la réforme qu'il
entendait mettre en place avant de
recevoir l'invité de cette édition et
pour commencer cette séquence votre avis
sur ces ZEP sont-elles efficaces
sont-ell trop cher quelques réponses
avec ce micro trottoir bah ces app ces
zones d'éducation prioritaire que je
connais depuis un certain temps bon ont
toujours été une bonne chose à condition
qu'on y mette les moyens et surtout les
enseignants volontaires derrière sinon
on peut avoir d'autres risques des zones
donc où les enfants sont pour moi plus
en difficulté et où on met en place
peut-être des choses un petit peu plus
adaptées pour pour eux ah benah écoutez
c'est des c'est les villes où d'abord où
il y a peu d'emplois de toute façon et
où les conditions de vie sont difficiles
ça c'est sûr quartier difficile ville
difficile école difficile ça tout le
monde le sait mais je pense que quand on
remet tout à plat faut remettre tout à
plat pour moi elles sont un peu
négatives je pense que le mieux enfin à
mon avis il vaut mieux faire le partage
qu'il y en est un petit peu partout
plutôt que de de parquer les gens comme
ça voilà je suis un peu disons que je
suis contre invité pour parler de cette
refonte des zones d'éducation
prioritaire annoncé aujourd'hui par le
ministre Vincent payon Bertrand mesure
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
départemental SN ppfsu basé à trpe on
vient d'entendre quelques micro trottoir
juste une réaction sur la toute dernière
personne qui s'est exprimée elle disait
être contre ces Z et cette cette volonté
de de parquer un petit peu les élèves de
catégoriser les comme ça les les
difficultés bah c'est sûr que le constat
qui est fait de façon récurrente c'est
que la mixité sociale est quelque chose
qui favorise la réussite des élèves
maintenant les zones d'éducation
prioritair sont le résultat d'une
politique d'urbanisme qui ne s'est pas
décrété sur les 10 der dernières années
donc c'est un un mouvement long profond
qui tend plus ou moins à être modifié
par tout ce qui concerne l'en rue avec
l'EN rue mais pour autant il fautation
uraine conc voà il faut bien prendre en
compte le fait qu'actuellement il existe
des zones comme celle-ci que des
établissements scolaires y sont
implantés et que les tentatives de de
bus scholing ce qu'on a appelé c'est
déplacer les élèves vers les
centre-ville n'ont pas duré bien
longtemps parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué alors en attendant que
effectivement les personnes et du
travail que les conditions sociales
s'améliorent et que du coup la mixité
sociale permett aux élèves de travailler
dans de meilleures conditions il faut
bien venir en aide à à ces populations
et les telleles qu'elles existent
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elles sont
inefficaces c'est pour ça qu'il faut les
revoir ça ne marche pas aujourd'hui
alors ça ne marche pas en tout cas ça ne
marche pas à la hauteur des ambitions
qu'on pourrait avoir puisque les
dernières études qui ont eu lieu les
études PISA pour ne pas les nommer
pointe le fait que les inégalités
augmentent au lieu de se réduire
néanmoins je ferai un petit bémol sur la
méthodologie des études PISA puisqueelle
elle vise à comparer par exemple une
ville comme shanghï avec des pays c'est
un peu comme si dans notre département
on on parait une ville comme trappe avec
baahli par exemple ça n'a pas beaucoup
de sens voilà donc à ces réserves
méthodologiques près en tout cas ce
qu'elle pointe et qui est intéressant
c'est que on on narrive pas à réduire le
le fossé qui se creuse entre les zones
les plus difficiles les résultats des
élèves qui sont dans les zones les plus
difficiles et les autres et c'est lié à
quoi c'est lié à la qualité de
l'enseignement qui est dispensé parce
qu'on parle toujours de moyens de moyens
supplémentaires mais est-ce que les
enseignants par exemple qui
interviennent sont formés est-ce que les
les moyens supplémentaires alors moi je
voudrais quand même resituer les choses
dans un autre contexte il y avait une un
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui avait
été fait il y a quelques années et qui
au lieu de prendre comme une unité de
compte les postes qui étaient mis
avaient pris comme unité de compte
l'euro et quand on prend l'unité de
compte euro on s'aperçoit que non
seulement il y a pas d'avantageif
significatif dans les collèges ou dans
les écoles ZEP mais que au contraire
l'avantage significatif il est dans les
collèges ou les écoles de de
centre-ville ou de communes plus
favorisées donc ça signifie quoi qu'on
met pas des moyens financier suffisant
ça veut dire que en en zone d'éducation
par prioritaire arrivent de jeunes
collègues qui sont au début de leur
carrière qui n'ont pas reçu de formation
spécifiques qui parfois viennent de très
loin puisqu'il faut quand même savoir
qu'énormément de collègues en
élémentaire en maternel ou en secondaire
commencent leur carrière sur les trois
académies parisiennes et voilà il y a
les fait d'paysement il y a tout ça qui
fait que c'est difficile pour un
collègue de commencer en ZEP dans un
milieu scolaire qui lui aussi n'est pas
très favorable avec des élèves en
difficulté avec des des immigrations de
prière ou 2e génération un contexte
social dégradé et cetera tout ça ne
participe pas de de bonnees conditions
de travail et puisqu'on on parlait de
moyen le le ministre a prévu de de un
certain nombre de choses et il y en a
qui sont positifes comme par exemple
celle de de libérer du temps pour les
enseignants de découpler le temps élèv
et le temps enseignant pour que les
enseignants puissent travailler ensemble
que ce soit en interdgré que ce soit en
intercycle ou au qu travailler ensemble
ils vont mettre en point des programmes
des méthodes faire des retours sur les
élèves encadrer certains élves ça permet
de mieux aménager les transitions qui
peut y avoir entre différents cycles
entre la maternelle élémentaire entre
l'élémentaire et le collège et donc de
de mieux préparer les élèves à ce qu'
sont des ruptures qui peut-être plus
qu'ailleurs sont assez pénalisantes dans
le parcours scolaire des enfants ça veut
dire qu'en discutant entre eux les
enseignants vont pouvoir mieux cerner
les difficultés des élèves parce qu'on
parle de dégager du temps mais
concrètement ce temps va servir à quoi
cerner les difficultés prévoir des des
des programmations des progressions
mieux connaître le l'élémentaire pour le
collège et mieux connaître le second
degré pour les les professeurs
d'élémentairire ça permet de de
construire un parcours scolaire de
l'élève qui s'inscrit dans une
continuité beaucoup plus qu'auellement
alors la réforme prévoit une nouvelle
pédagogie un nouveau climat scolaire des
équipes éducatives plus efficaces voilà
pour les annonces de ce que vous savez
ce que vous avez entendu jusqu'à présent
vous nous dites ça va plutôt dans le bon
sens alors il y a des choses qui vont
dans le bon sens déjà la volonté
affirmée de de faire en sorte que
l'accueil des 2 ans soit favorisé le
ministre veut arriver à 30 % il faut
savoir que sur l'académie de Versailles
on est autour de 5 6 % donc voilà ça
c'est un premier point parce que
l'accueil précoce dans les bonnes
conditions qui ont été mises en place
l'année dernière avec ces classes un peu
particulière permet aux élèves d'arriver
à l'école maternelle et de mieux
profiter de l'école maternelle parce que
ça commence à ce moment-là et un élève
qui réussit bien son école maternelle
c'est un élève qui est mieux préparé
pour l'élémentaire mieux préparé à
entrer dans la lecture et on sait que
c'est vraiment sur le sur ces
difficultés très très fondamentales que
beaucoup d'élèves de de Zep échouent
alors on va aussi parler à l'avenir
maintenant de réseau d'éducation
prioritaire on change une lettre ce ne
sont plus des zones d'éducation
prioritaire juste une petite
modification pour montrer qu'il y a une
réforme ou ça va changer quelque chose
non alors on abandonne le dispositif
éclair qui qui était un peu qui avait un
peu vocation à mettre de la poudre aux
yeux on va pass on va parler de REP plus
bon tout ça c'est des cycles très
administratifs ce qui est intéressant
c'est le contenu et c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure si on veut
fidéliser des équipes si on veut faire
en sorte que des des enseignants
chevronnés viennent en zone d'éducation
par prioritaire c'est les conditions de
travail qu'il faut améliorer il faut les
payer plus aussi alors ça passe
évidemment par une rémunération par par
qu'il est question de revaloriser les
salaires avec la réform c'est c'est pas
revaloriser les salaires mais c'est
faire en sorte que les collègues qui
viennent travailler dans ces zones-l a
des indemnités plus importantes comme je
le disais tout à l'heure ce sont des
jeunes collègues qui arrivent pour
l'instant et c'est vrai qu'il trouvent
des difficultés à se loger des
difficultés à se déplacer en région
parisiennne et ça ne peut être que
positif mais en soit ça n'est pas
suffisant ce que nous avons demandé et
ce qui semble être en passe de se mettre
en place aussi c'est la possibilité de
diminuer les effectifs de faire en sorte
que le le nombre d'élèves par enseignant
puisse être un petit peu assoupli de
façon à avoir des des conditions de de
travail plus efficaces c'est une
revendication assez fondamentale des
enseignants et qui a qui s'est
particulièrement fait jour lors des
Assises de l'éducation prioritaire donc
plus d'enseignants plus d'enseignants
mais pas que des enseignants il y a
aussi des infirmières scolaires qui vont
venir qui vont travailler dans le
premier degré moi quand je suis arrivé
sur trap il y a quelques années on avait
des infirmières dans le premier degré
qui faisaient un travail remarquable
dans l'éducation à la santé dans
l'éducation au corps et c'est important
que c'est des personnel autre que des
enseignants puissent venir et aider les
enseignants à faire progresser les
élèves il y a aussi l'accueil
envieolaire qui va permettre aussi de de
d'avoir un taux d'encadrement par des
adultes plus importants au collège et
qui permettra de résoudre un certain
nombre de problèmes tout ne va pas
changer du jour au lendemain une fois
que la réforme va se mettre en place et
en plus la réforme va se mettre
progressivement en place dans les
collèges dans les établissements à
travers la France il va falloir combien
d'années pour qu'enfin le système arrive
un petit peu à son équilibre et que ses
élèves des zones d'éducation
prioritaires arrivent à s'en sortir
aussi bien que les autres alors écoutez
aussi bien que les autres resterait à
préciser ce que veut dire aussi bien que
les autres je RTE moins de difficulté
moins de discrimination jeens à ce que
je disais tout à l'heure par rapport à à
PISA euh mais ce qui ce qui est
important aussi c'est qu'on change le
contenu hein vous savez que aussi bien
en ce qui concerne la réforme des
rythmes scolaires que laéducation
prioritaire pour pour l'instant on est
resté on va dire sur le le le contenant
reste à modifier le contenu il y a un
certain nombre de points qui nous
satisfont pas comme par exemple l'école
du socle le fait que pour tout le
primaire on nit pas changé les
programmes donc ça aussi ça va être des
éléments importants parce que ce qu'on
met en place les conditions d'exercice
sont importantes mais il y a aussi ce
qu'on vient faire à l'école qui mais
justement une dernière question
aujourd'hui ça ce dossier là pour de
votre point de vue en tant que
qu'enseignant ça n'avance pas assez vite
ces questions du contenu qu'est-ce qu'on
fait faire aux élèves qu'est-ce qu'on le
apprend aujourdhui écoutez envie de dire
que ce qu'il y a de positif dans les
propositions qui sont faites c'est
qu'elles sont pluréannuelles donc en ce
qui concerne les programmes nous
souhaitons des modifications néanmoins
il faut que celle-ci puisse s'inscrire
dans la durée parce que ce dont l'école
a besoin c'est de duré par exemple le
système finlandais qu'on met souvent en
exerg a mis 20 ans à modifier son
système et il y a eu un consensus qui a
permis de modifier les choses sur la
durée donc il est nécessaire que là on
commence avec des choses qui nous
semblent positives mais maintenant il
faut qu'elle puisse s'inscrire dans la
durée et qu'elle ne soit pas liée à la
vie d'un cabinet ministériel et on sait
il y a des élections si jamais il y a
des changements on pourrait revenir sur
ces modifications qui sont annoncer
écoutez c'est pas à moi qu'il faut poser
la question nous est-ce que ça vous
inquiète en tout cas si les choses
devaient encore évoluer s'il y a un
changement encore de cap dans les
prochains mois oh je pense pas dans les
prochains mois les engagements qu'a pris
le ministre semblent être sur 4 ans donc
euh acceptons en l'augure et puis
faisons en sorte que les choses
s'améliorent sur 4 ans mais votre
volonté c'est de travailler dans la
durée en tout cas merci
mesure d'être venu commenteres annonces
de Vincent payOnes annonces autour des
nouveautés concernant les zones
d'éducation prioritaire zon d'éducation
prioritaire qui vont donc changer dès la
rentrée merci encore à vous merci une
semaine après leur lancement les solldes
de divers 2014 affichent un bilan plutôt
décevant chiffre d'affaires en chute de
5 à 10 % dans l'habillement nous sommes
allés dans un centre commercial un peu
particulier one nation Paris c'est un
centre dédié aux marques de luxe à pris
réduit il a ouvert ses portes il y a
moins d'un mois au clés sousbois comment
se passe cette première période de solde
pour les commerçants le point avec
Olivier Maniscalco et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud nous venons de de selogne parce
qu'on avait entendu parler effectivement
de ce
centre de marque dégriffé et en plus en
sold donc c'est c'est vrai que c'est
c'est super intéressant il suffit on a
les bras un peu
chargés oui tout dépend pour qui voilà
même si le premier bilan des soldes
divers semble mitigé pour les enseignes
de mode avec une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires de 5 à 10 % en France
à one nation Paris au clés sous-bois on
semble ne pas connaître la crise avec
80000 visiteurs du 8 au 12 janvier les
tiroir caiss se sont bien remplis pour
ce nouveau complexe que les clients
viennent découvrir un nouvel équipement
commercial dans une zone qui est déjà
très populaire donc bien sûr ça a joué
ce qui a surtout joué je pense c'est le
fait que nos prix sont tous les jours
très bas on a moin 30 % de démarque tous
les jours et les soldes viennent de
s'appliquer sur ces prix déjà démarqués
donc les gens l'ont compris des gens qui
qui pourtant peuvent bénéficier toute
l'année de promotion via les sites
internet spécialisés ou les nombreuses
boutiques qui proposent régulièrement
des Rabet intéressant mais là encore
l'effet nouveauté du centre semble
opérer je pense que ça fa un peu la
donne parce que certains clients V être
beaucoup moins impatient de manière
générale vu qu'il y a des soldes un peu
toute l'année des soldes flottantes on
va dire que les les clients qui sont
venus sont venus pour acheter parce
qu'il sa ils avaient fait du repérage
avant la période des soldes donc on a
une hausse de peu près 10 % au niveau
fréquentation par contre le chiffre on
est passé du au double même au triple
selon les journées autre explication des
bons chiffres les navettes gratuites
mises en place depuis Paris pour
transporter les clients vers les
boutique il vous reste jusqu'au 11
février date de la fin des soldes pour
en
profiter une bière avec modération mais
aussi en chanson un ivelinois a trouvé
le moyen de réunir ses deux passions le
brassage de la bière et la musique
depuis de mois il propose à Grignon ses
création au connotation musicales à un
concept étonnant que vous propose de
découvrir claire
Cambier à la ferme de Grignon la
brasserie district a ouvert ses portes
fin 2013 parmi les bières proposées
confusion du nom d'une chanson de New
Order ou encore Factory comme le label
de musique pour Alexandre Bournonville
le brasseur musique et bière ces deux
passions sont indissociables le jour où
j'ai commencé à à brasser de toute façon
c'était c'était en musique c'est
toujours assez assez dynamique avec une
bonne une bonne une bonne ambiance et
j'ai essayé de de créer des des recettes
était dans l'esprit de la musique que
j'écoutais ce ce jourl donc CIT une
recette un petit peu péchue je mettais
de la musique dynamique ou la musique un
petit peu plus calme ici on brasse donc
en musique les commandes grossi au fil
du temps Alexandre produit aujourd'hui
10000 bouteilles par mois dans sa
collection cinq bières à chacune sa
particularité et son style musical j'ai
typiquement la la clashche qui est la
bière la plus la plus ro qui va être une
bière brune type porteur typiquement
c'est les bières de Londres historique
comme comme clash et comme leur titre
London cing donc je conseille de la
boire avec London cing Alexandre
s'occupe de la production de A à Z et sa
femme l'IDE durant son temps libre après
une carrière dans les Télécom cet
ingénieur a changé de vie pour vivre de
sa passion déjà petit mes parents sont
agriculteurs de
voir de se demander comment était fait
la bière c'est que mon père faisait de
l'orge de brasserie du BL pour les
brasseries aussi chaque fois j'ai
entendu ça toute ma jeunesse je suis dit
mais comment ça vient de la bière après
quelques mois le BR a vite dépassé le
statut de passemp une activité qu'il
exerce à temps plein depuis maintenant 6
mois il propose régulièrement des
sessions
d'initiation l'univers Warhammer lancé
en 1983 continue à séduire les amateurs
de jeux de figurines le monde
fantastique qui s'inspire aussi bien de
l'époque médiévale que des romans de
Tolkien compte des millions d'adeptes à
travers le monde à voisin le Bretonneux
les ivelinois se réunissent chaque année
pour un tournoi la 5e édition vient de
se terminer Catherine zulato
on va voir déjà si je
touche ouais comme c'est r
sable amori pratique le waramer depuis
une dizaine d'années un jeu de plateau
qui se compose d'une armée formée par
des figurines que chaque joueur doit
assembler et peindre lui-même chaque
figurine va avoir des
caractéristiques un historique pour
expliquer comment elle se elle se
débrouille sur champ de bataille et
comme dans la vraie vie militaire il y a
des chefs des chars et des esquades le
jeu a été créé en Angleterre par une
société qui développait les jeux de
rôles aux alentours des années 90 les
règles sont très précises par exemple il
faut mesurer les distances du mouvement
et cela se fait en pouce on mesure les
portées des armes on mesure les
déplacements on mesure les distances qui
nous séparent des objectifs lorsqu'il
faut prendre des objectifs on mesure les
distances pour les zones de déploiement
une partie dure en moyenne 3h au
centrealfred de Vigny à voisin le
Bretonneux un tournoi été organisé sur 2
jours assemblant 150 mordus certains
sont donc venus pour jouer d'autres pour
continuer le leur collection et
améliorer leurs techniques de peinture
c'est vraiment aller expliquer les
différentes techniques de peinture donc
il y a ce qu'on appelle le brossage à
sec il y a le dégradé de couleur
l'éclaircissement intensif et tout ça ça
permet de mettre en valeur la figurine
une passion qui a un coup pour monter
une armée il faut au moins débourser 200
€ le centre propose des ateliers tout au
long de l'année autre univers depuis
l'an dernier l'Académie des lumières
propose ses récompenses au meilleurs
film français ou francophone une
manifestation en partenariat avec 3IS
l'Institut international de l'image et
du son à H encour et dans ce cadre des
projections sont prévues jusqu'au 28
janvier premier rendez-vous le 21
janvier au ciné 7 à hencour pour
découvrir le sac de farine de cadija
Leclerc l'histoire vraie d'une
adolescente entre la Belgique et le
Maroc dont voici la
bandeannonce pardonnez-moi mon père
parce que j'ai péché
Sarah je ne veux plus que tu viennes te
confesser comme ça tous les jours
pourquoi je n'ai pas un
papa
[Musique]
bonjour s je suis ton
papa VI pas peur tu es musulmane c'est
pour ton bien que tu te ramèn dans la
famille
[Musique]
m et toi S c'est quoi
ton je vais partir en Belgique et
personne doit le
[Musique]
savoir
tte mais ba la tête tu veux nous mettre
h TU
s je doisc 200 pour les étudiants du
collègeouver
prison
[Musique]
ce qui compte c'est l'amour pas la
virginité
madame et la réalisatrice sera présente
ce 21 janvier au ciné dès 20h30 avec son
équipe pour échanger avec le public pour
terminer ce 78 un portrait à présent
Matthieu Villar est installé à Montini
le bretonneis il pratique le florball
une discipline quasiment inconnue il n'y
a d'ailleurs que 10 clubs en première
division dans le pays une équipe de
France féminine vient tout juste d'être
créée découverte d'une discipline en
pleine évolution Antony chez Claire
Cambier c'est lors d'un séjour étudiant
en Suède que matthu Villar découvre le
florball rien ne l'indique dans le nom
de ce sport mais c'est en quelque sorte
le petit frère du hockey sur gllace ici
pas de patin ni de palais mais une cross
en carbone et une balle creuse c'est
moins technique moins violent quand même
que le hoy sur gllace mais c'est il y a
tout autant de dépenses physiques
vraiment on n'arrête pas de courir on
transpire beaucoup et puis ça reste
ludique on a une crosse il faut pouvoir
contrôler la balle faire des passes à
ses coéquipiers il y a un côté tactique
également le florball se joue à 5 contre
5 l'objectif marquer plus de buts que
l'équipe adverse sur un terrain de 40 m
de long par 20 m de large les rotations
s'opèrent toutes les 2 à 3 minutes ici
le contact est interdit sauf à l'épaule
et surtout c'est accessible à tous frè
rapidement on prend du plaisir à jouer
puisque même si on contrôle pas
exactement la balle on arrive quand même
à faire des passes ou avancer avec la
balle même si c'est pas parfait et donc
on prend rapidement du plaisir la
légende raconte que le flball serait
arrivé en France dans les sous-sols de
l'ambassade de Suède créé officiellement
2002 le sport compte désormais 27 clubs
et approche la barre des 1000 licenciés
et il y a quelques mois une équipe de
France féminine a même vu le jour il y a
un gros changement déjà il y a beaucoup
plus d'équipes qui se challenge
et qui qui peuvent se battre entre elles
déjà dans la dans la première division
alors que pendant longtemps il y avait
quelques équipes qui qui dominaient donc
automatiquement bah on voit que ça se
resser niveau tresser beaucoup de clubs
sont de plus en plus sérieux a des
entraînements sérieux certaines
cherchent même à apprendre à avoir des
des entraîneurs dédiés des coach dédier
sur le banc pour débuter vous devrez
vous équiper d'une cross à 30 € d'une
bonne paire de basket adapté et surtout
d'un super fair playay rendez-vous
demain à 18h pour faire le point sur
l'actualité du jour et également sur
celle de la semaine écoulée dans le
département votre rendez-vous de la
soirée sur TV fil c'est filcho à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain